it's time for a pick from the little
yellow book which is my personal guide
to all things i need to share with you
and today it's an incredible online tool
it's the can i binge calculator i am
here for this if you ever wanted to
binge a show but weren't sure if you had
enough time or how to do it or how to go
about it this is the tool for you you
type in the show
the amount of time you've got
and it tells you exactly how many
episodes you need to watch every day to
get it done yeah succession guess what
you can watch it all in one week if you
did four episodes a day that's it never
seen sopranos maybe now's the time watch
it in just one month with three episodes
a day snl easy 15 episodes a day for two
months straight and you're done now
that's a bit yes ross what are you going
to binge next well i just have to say
this is what i have needed in my life
because i take it very seriously i need
like 18 recommendations from friends
before i commit to a show so thank you
for this isn't this a cool yeah and i'm
going to see next i'm going to watch
squid games that's my next bingo yeah
should we watch it together so we can
discuss it i hear it's fairly scary so
i'm committing to the first 20 minutes i
think it's only just like i think it's
more like kill bill hunger games like
it's not like what would totally
terrorize us okay is it worth it should
i watch it
okay i'm in raise of hands how many
people like squid game
this is a global phenomenon so it is our
duty to watch it is our civic duty tool
that's right
all right well thank you everybody truly
for choosing to spend your time with us
we make this show for you so take this
good energy with you and we'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]